non è la scelta giusta Amica mia ma stai
scherzando
[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata oggi mi farò un
tè insieme a Michela girorò Ciao
Io ti ringrazio
complimenti per il tuo speciale su
Netflix perché qui abbiamo la prima
donna in Italia ad aver fatto Stendardo
su Netflix mica [ __ ] miei come
Scusami Complimenti Grazie mille Senza
contare che tu mi hai un tour
di qualcosa Non lo so eh Cioè nel senso
mi inviti a questo tour Posso venirti a
vedere Certo devi venire tu devi il 17
maggio al Brancaccio il link qui ti
offro subito qualcosa da bere
Allora io ti ho detto che sto astemia Ma
che è sto plotone di tossicità un
Marghera ma non c'è tipo metà degli
ingredienti quindi faccio
il Marco lo facciamo insieme adesso
tequila una lacrima perché se no
questo Scusa poi un pochino di ghiaccio
perché deve Ma questo Sembra quello che
ha fatto fuori il Titanic la quantità di
ghiaccio
che sia chiaro
[Musica]
mi fa fare
col coltello
[Musica]
Ma cosa del tè al volo Ti apro questo ti
preparo anche le tazzine allora
questa ti piace Fidati
Poi devi finire
qua la cosa delle monsoda eh
Voglio vedere fino a dove arrivi Beh sei
un artista
basta ma in senso non è la zolletta ce
l'avete dei modi siamo pronti per una
puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
mamma mia porca [ __ ]
già glielo ho sempre Ammirato per le tue
doti che non comprendono poi Margarita
mi piaceva Guarda quanto è bravo questo
e io che un po' C'avevo La musichella
che volevo fare teatro ma anche non lo
sapevo e poi di nascosto a casa
Ti prego amami Sposami ci sono dei Ti
prego amami Sposami di me di 10 anni fa
e Margarita continua a fare video come
essere We will ce l'ha fatta invece
guarda io sono molto scaramantica quindi
mentre tu mi parli io devo toccare Ferro
cose Guarda In realtà io non mi rendo
mai conto delle cose che
succe- avevo già capito dove stavi
andando
emozionale in cui faccio finta di essere
modesta sì e lui la troncato male Male
Grazie Wii Dominick con una mia ex
compagna di classe e mmm due professori
era sera erano verdi fuori e la
professoressa mi ha detto Robi prendi
questo tavolo e io gli ho portato il
tavolo direttamente in mano allora
questa persona adesso in questo momento
liberatela ha bisogno di tornare dalla
sua famiglia tempo fa stavo con un
ragazzo che mi criticava sempre per la
mia forma fisica quando mi ha lasciata
ho deciso di prendermi la mia rivincita
andando tutti i giorni in palestra e
rimettendomi in forma ovviamente mesi
dopo lui è tornato e All'inizio
chiaramente non ne volevo sapere ma la
verità è che io ancora provo qualcosa
per lui quindi Ultimamente ci stiamo
risentendo io non so se la scelta giusta
ma purtroppo provo ancora qualcosa per
lui e non credo che riuscirò a dirgli no
non è la scelta giusta amica mia Tu lo
stai facendo solamente perché pensi di
non meritare di meglio ma tu meriti
molto di meglio e lo meritava anche da
te prima della palestra molla Sto
stronzo brava Io volevo arriva' qua
Guardate Intanto questo audio ci è
arrivato calcolando due giorni fa Quindi
che rivincita Eh secondo me veniva
voglia di semplicemente di dimostrare di
essere ancora desiderabile per un'altra
persona lei è schiava dell'immagine che
questo ragazzo le dà e lei non ha Chiara
qual è la sua immagine non ti serve
questa persona per dirti chi sei tu lo
sai Chi sei La sottona in questo momento
in questo momento
siamo molto buoni l'unica che sia chiaro
tu cioè io non ti ho invitato qua per
uscire con dei commenti sgradevoli
perché io li farò io sono ubriaca già
Figurati una forte delusione amorosa te
lo ricordo tu ne parlasti tu ti vergogni
di quello che sei stato No no Hai fatto
pace con questa cosa no cioè nel senso
ho fatto pace con quella cosa
non mi dispiacerebbe sapere però non con
cattiveria dai Martina quello però 40 km
orari non è terribile terribile
Vabbè manda avanti no devi migliorarla
tutto sai che il tuo programma
sono solo io che ridere le tue battute
eh ah ah ah
dice battute di merda io hahaha
dopo che è finito tutto quanto io mi
sono buttato in palestra Cioè hai
presente io mi sarei Scotto da solo ma
tu lasci bello a me piacevi molto Ti
ringrazio perché vuol dire Madò detto
Claudio Amendola
Ma stai scherzando
Eccolo che ha fatto la serie con Carlo
Verdone Carlo ma tu sei impazzito Io me
ne vado ma tu sei impazzito Claudio
Amendola ma io non so i nomi con le
facce Eh
certo Comunque Claudio Amendola capito
l'amico mio fisico
mai avuto prima adesso a me non me ne
frega un cazzo ma per quella delusione
No però la delusione è un motore Anche a
me è capitato Eh ma poi si è fermato
quel motore perché non continuo quello
motore è sempre una sono gli altri che
hanno la spinta esterna se noi avessimo
la spinta interna non ci avremmo tutti i
problemi che c'abbiamo siamo all'interno
di una società che Proietta
continuamente dei bisogni è chiaro che
mo dai soddisfatto un bisogno Apri
Instagram Instagram
no no no nel senso è la comica più forte
d'Italia Cioè hai deciso proprio oggi
dei [ __ ] nel senso
Michela Sei tu che non sai la verità che
io sono una persona che attacca delle
mie amiche
il gioco tu mi sei attrice interprete
veicolo di emozioni Musa artista e
giocoliera
[Musica]
questa cosa accadrà questa cosa accadrà
lo dichiariamo da subito questa cosa
cadrà tutto bene Sì qui abbiamo delle
frasi frasi di qualsiasi tipo sono delle
quotes e qui abbiamo delle intenzioni Io
c'ho un punto debole cioè uno di queste
emozioni che non so fare non te la dico
lo capirai lo dovete scegliere a turno
un numero quel numero sarà quello che
noi dovremmo fare indovinare all'altro
allora inizio io
non fanno ridere quando sei Sei stata
sei stata male Sono venuta e ti ho fatto
sei un cane però eh
un clistere e mia cara
mia cara Tiè [ __ ] Tiè reazione
importante Sai quanti cereali sottomarca
devi mangiare ancora
ho costipato ma non lo comprerò
e spaventato
Silvio D'Amico non ho mai voluto Ciao
ha fatto il coso che hai lanciato nata
principessa eh Non mi devi vedere
lattorialità data principessa
cresciuta guerriera un angelo bianco
con l'anima nera arrogante
sembra proprio di stare a Rio de Janeiro
stanco
Ti prego
mi sono sentita sposata
[Applauso]
non l'avevo vista agguerrito
brutte intenzioni la maleducazione
la tua brutta figura
Ieri sera tutto Sappilo la tua
gratitudine la tua ignoranza
neanche una lacrima
una bella che hai dentro provocante
Brava brava grandissima Ah ok Il numero
è quello sopra
la torre
cazzo
io sono indeciso tra sexy eccitato me la
puoi rifare
sexy Sì
Autorizzo
il mio ufficio legale in questo momento
a procedere
la rifaccio No per carità Mi sa che ho
capito dovevo rifammela Guarda guarda
provocatorio forse direi disperato
nella recitazione per veicolare
un'emozione benissimo a lei
non l'ho appena fatto io autorizzo
no Scusate non ho capito il gioco gelato
Wow
pure il tabellone si è rotto il cazzo di
noi
tu non vieni qua
a casa mia e fai lo show tuo perché lo
show Quando inizia e quando finisce
io io
e ti ho detto tutto e quello che che tu
sei l'ho capito tutto
E tu hai fatto tutto questo quando ero
incinta dal mio primo figlio ti ricordi
che cosa hai fatto Cosa hai fatto 13
anni fa ah ah io lo so a memoria quel
monologo Ma io ti dico che chiaramente è
ubriaco Grazie perché tu ti racconti le
storie tu non vieni qua e fai lo so a
casa mia chiudetevi l'audio Ciao
Fabrizio buona vita
questo biscotto che io
mangio davanti a voi
e vi invito ad andare nei ristoranti
cinesi
stupenda chiaramente annoiata esatto
[Musica]
provocatoria lo sono
l'unica cosa bella di te è il mio
riflesso nei tuoi occhi
Guarda sono indecisa tra eccitato
l'entusiasta ma penso che sceglierò
depresso
il mio tallone d'Achille Spero che non
da killer speravamo Ma io volevo
diventare famosa ma non era questo il
mio obiettivo
però volevo fare qualcosa che
avesse senso
questo Nessuno mi ha mai portato
fisicamente ad avere questa reazione a
niente
ma io Mmm non volevo diventare famoso Sì
io voglio fare questa però te voglio fa
per come te la direi io mi hanno gettata
in mezzo ai lupi e ne sono uscita a capo
Branco mi hanno gettato in mezzo ai lupi
e
e ne sono uscita capo bomba ragazzi mi
hanno gettata in mezzo ai lupi e ne sono
uscita a capobranco Soy Una Diabla
cigamà io non so che abbia vinto ma
comunque abbiamo dimostrato una sola
cosa che il talento non se compra da
nessuna parte Grazie mille Michela
veramente pazzesca qua
come si deve accavallare le gambe una
ragazza in TV
a questa poveraccia Allora è così perché
dall'altro lato è sbagliato cioè così è
sbagliato la lunghezza della gamba e non
si deve vedere in mezzo dove ognuno ha
quel che vuole
gente che medicina avevano dubbi a
Bologna avevo questi grandi
conversazioni intellettuali primo
appuntamento Ti posso offrire una
bottiglia
la risposta è stata no E quindi
giustamente Cosa si fa in questi casi si
alza la vostra in gioco ovvero ti posso
dare addosso
io ti chiedo scusa naturalmente verrà io
non li ascolto prima non lo potevo
sapere ho solo un'ultima domanda da
farci
tu cosa faresti con una persona con la
quale ti senti da un po' di tempo e che
ti Lancia sta roba così all'improvviso
No no ma tipo poi scappi non ti fai più
sentire Dipende che rapporto siamo se
tipo mio padre
può capitare che delle persone che
frequenti con cui ci dicono dei proposte
per esempio a me quando m'hanno detto
una volta di fare una cosa a tre io non
ce l'ho fatta me lo sai perché Perché
uno si vuole portare all'amico suo ha
detto questo mi ruba dentro casa
ruba in casa ma per quello Assolutamente
no
Ciao a tutti
Ma così la finiamoci abbiamo tempo
siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata
Michela Io ti ringrazio di cuore Netflix
ma non ho mai fatto il Chuck il primo
Chakra che fanno da Nora
c'era qua
ci trattano male eh
Grazie per avermi invitato Grazie a te
per essere venuta ti possiamo vedere su
Netflix la verità lo giuro e possiamo
anche vederti in tour Sì mi potete
vedere dal vivo così Se mi volete venire
a menare avete questa occasione Però
bisogna vedere io come Mamma mia
qua sotto c'è il link Mi raccomando per
acquistare i biglietti detto ciò noi ci
vediamo sempre qui ma non so quando
basta Stop Abbiamo finito Ok ciao senti
Grazie mille per avermi invitato Sono
stata veramente molto contenta
No no fai vuoi riprendere i piedi
Ciao ragazzi
Grazie per essere qui
lo sai che io ho fatto cinema panettone
poi alla fine io non sono più che cazzo
fa che c'è un centrino
salutiamo
Il Matrimonio a Parigi
Ciao Basta
È veramente ci sei in tour amore
cominciamo
su Netflix
[Musica]